[MUSIC PLAYING]
JENS KUEHLERS: All
right, welcome, everyone.
This is the last
session of the show,
so thanks for coming to this
one, I really appreciate it.
And I'm going to talk
about visualizing
network topologies and traffic.
But I have an
awesome team with me.
I have With me Arunima,
who is a UX researcher.
She's based in Seattle.
And I have Greg, who's an
engineering manager working
on networking and tooling.
And he's based in Warsaw.
So I'm going to introduce
you to the agenda real quick,
so we're going to know
what we're talking about.
And let's talk
about traffic flows
and how we do visualize those
in an on premises network.
I'm always going
to introduce that.
And then I'm going to talk about
how we can do it in the cloud
today.
Then I'm going to give
over to our Arunima,
and she's going to
tell about research
we've done on what
else users want
about network visualization
and what we found out there.
And then I'm going to segue
to the topology section
and what's been
possible there till now.
And Greg's going to
introduce a shiny new product
we built around that.
So let's get started
with traffic.
And I come from
an ISP background.
I worked in a couple of ISPs.
I started as a network
engineer in Google.
So when I made the switch
to the cloud five years ago,
I felt a little bit uneasy.
The tools I've been
looking, the dashboards
I've been using every day,
they don't work anymore.
I was missing my tools.
The data wasn't there
anymore, I couldn't find it,
and I was like, what's
this with cloud?
Everything's different,
this is not good.
I felt a little bit like a
kid on the playground getting
his favorite toys taken away.
But over time, I got
more comfortable.
I realized you might have
to step a little bit out
of your comfort zone when you
make the switch to the cloud.
Maybe you need to look a
little bit somewhere different
for the data you're looking
for, and it's not all that bad.
So I'm going to
introduce you to that.
Let's first look at what you
might have done in the past.
So when you visualize traffic,
there's lots of tools around.
Open source and
commercial tools,
they all kind of
do the same thing.
They read some
counters over SNMP,
the aggregate them, they
take out overflow data.
And then they visualize
them and store
all the data in a database.
And that's how you
visualize layer two data.
So you can't get
anything about protocols.
If you want to dig
deeper, you need
to use any of these
flow-like protocols.
Netflow, jFlow, sFlow,
more recently, IPFIX.
And they also all kind
of work the same way.
You have a router or
switch exporting flow data.
And you have a couple of
collectors who take that data
and store it in a database.
And then you have some tools
to analyze the data around.
What's a little bit difficult
is getting 100% coverage.
So in this example here, you
can see we collect the data
right next to the firewall.
So while everything
going in and out
is captured, if
you don't capture
data between the servers.
In other ways, when you
have a lot of exporters,
you might capture
some flow as double,
and then you have to
subtract them up again,
so it's kind of a
little bit difficult.
So once you do collect the
data, what do people do with it?
And we see a few
common use cases there.
The first one everyone first
looks at desktop top talkers.
You see in your
network who generates
the most traffic,
outside of your network,
where does it go
to find anomalies
or something like that.
Some people use it
for capacity planning,
because you get
autonomous system numbers,
you can decide who might
you want to peer with,
where do you need to augment
capacity, something like that.
And in the security
area, people might
look at anomalies, small packet
sizes, lots of UDP traffic.
And they either do that through
some specialized tools or they
export all the data in the same
system they're using across.
Last use case we commonly
see is to verify other data.
So I have been seeing an ISPs
where they look at NetFlow data
to see if their bill they get
from another ISP is correct.
It's not something good
enough and granular enough
to actually create a
bill, but you can double
check data you generate
in another way.
So that's how you might
have done it on premises.
Now how does map to the cloud?
What data do you
have available there?
Let's first look at the
interface traffic again.
And you might not
have found a tab,
but actually right in the GCP
console, if you go to a VM,
there's network tab and you
can visualize bytes and packets
for every VM.
So quite similar to what
you've seen on the first slide
in on premises.
With Stackdriver
monitoring, you can
create these aggregate
graphs you might get used to.
So that's quite similar as well.
But you might want to
use your own tools.
You might want to export that.
And Stackdriver monitoring also
has Stackdriver monitoring API,
so you can export that data
to any tool you'd want,
either your existing ones
or you have something new.
And if you ever wrote
any tool that used SNMP,
you will be very happy to
not anymore use it, but just
use RESTful API instead.
Now there's also
elements in networking
which you have in
cloud, which you don't
have the same way on premises.
Like our global load balancer.
You don't have a global
balancing element in your
on premise network.
And we also can export
some data there.
Similar in the console, we can
show you quite some nice graphs
of where does your
traffic come from, which
backend group does it go to.
But if you actually go into
this Stackdriver monitoring,
you can get further metrics.
Like we can see
the round trip time
on the front end and the total
round trip time of TCP flows.
And you can use them right
there to create alerts,
or you can export
them through the API.
We also have a regional
load balancer product.
The metrics there are
slightly different,
but again, you get some
data around the load
balance through Stackdriver
monitoring, and its API.
So that looks quite good.
But of what about flow data?
Well, I'm pleased to say that we
recently launched VPC Flow Logs
NGA.
So that's our flow-level
network telemetry product.
So what does that mean?
It means every five
seconds all the TCP and UDP
flows get locked and
sampled and exported
to Stackdriver logging.
So what does it mean?
Is it like NetFlow?
Well, it's like NetFlow,
but it's not NetFlow.
So what's different?
First of all, we have
some exciting features
you don't have in NetFlow.
We can export the
exact IP of the flow.
We don't limit you to a subnet
[? selection ?] default level.
And we add a lot of
useful annotations to it,
so you don't have to
do that to yourself.
Like the name of the instance,
the name of the VPC subnet,
the regions done, et
cetera on the site.
And some more, which I will
go into a little bit later.
But not everything which
is there in NetFlow
is there in VPC Flow Logs.
First of all, we capture
by flow and not by packet.
So we can't give you
the packet tether
We didn't see too many people
actually using the full packet
tether, so this seems to be OK.
People also like the AS numbers.
They wanted to see peer
end destination AS.
Well, you might not really
care about who you appear with,
so let's not care what peer AS.
But since people really
want the destination AS,
this is an annotation
we recently added.
So you can now see
the destination
AS number right into the Flow
Log as one of the annotations.
But also not the same.
Obviously, it's a
different log format,
and we have all this
useful annotations,
so you can't use the
existing collectors.
You need to build a
different data pipeline.
But we do have exports
right out of box
to BigQuery, Cloud
Storage and [INAUDIBLE]..
And you can create
alerts on Stackdriver
that's right for it.
And through these
tools, you can easily
integrate with other
topology tools.
I'm also going to show that.
Let's look at the packet
format a little bit in detail.
And I say it's
enriched by default.
Like other providers
might give you
like a single line
of a log, which
gives you a source and
destination IP and a little bit
more.
We give you rich
json of information
with all these annotations, like
the instance name and subnet
name.
But also stuff like the round
trip time on every TCP flow,
because we can infer
that from seeing packets
going in both direction.
Or the location of
the external entity
on the city level, country
level or continent level.
So that's very, very useful.
And some data you
might otherwise
have to collect and add in a
very complex way to your data.
And you have full
coverage by default.
You don't have to care anymore
where to put your exporters.
All the traffic within the
VPC is by default, exported.
Traffic coming in
through interconnect,
through VPN, through the
internet directly to a VM
or through a load
balancer and to
and from other Google services.
So you see it all.
Now you have the data,
what can you do with it?
First of all, through the
integration with BigQuery,
it's very easy to do
quick visualizations.
And I'm going to demo
this with Data Studio.
Other people might use
something like Tableau
or anything else which
integrates in that area.
You can also build
complex data pipelines.
You can use Cloud Data Flow.
If you like Hadoop, you
can use Dataproc instead.
Or if you don't
use it that often,
you can just query
that data ad hoc
and build queries in BigQuery
whenever you need it.
And in the security space,
we see two use cases.
Either you export that
data through PubsHub
into your CYME software
and we tried out a few,
it works quite easily.
Or again, when you have
a security incident,
you can easily just through
the BigQuery interface,
dig into your data and find
out what might be going wrong.
But let's demo this.
Switch to the demo please.
Can we switch to the demo?
Not yet, there we go.
All right, so I have
an application built
and it has a global
load balancer,
and it's running in
three continents,
and it's a simple
web application.
So let's start
exporting flow logs.
So all I need to do
is select a subnetwork
where I want to
export flow logs.
So I select the US.
I added it, I toggle the
flow logs, and actually
tells me right away how
much data that will generate
in Stackdriver logging.
So let's save this.
And within a few
seconds, it will actually
start generating that
logging information.
So let's go out to
Stackdriver logging
and show the life
tale of the data.
So you can see all
these logs coming in
right away on what kind flows
might be generated there.
And you can look at the
json data, which I've seen,
so that works right
out of the box.
But looking then in Stackdriver
logging, not too useful
once you want to do analysis.
So let's create an export
of that data to BigQuery.
Let's call it VPC
flow logs next.
I say I going to
create it to BigQuery
and I create a new
dataset, VPC flows, create.
So when I create that
thing, within let's say
a minute or two, that gets
streamed into BigQuery
and you can query it right
away, all the data coming in.
It's nearly immediate.
However, for demo purposes,
a minute is quite long.
And also having a half a
minute or a minute of data
is not so interesting
to look at,
so I started this
expert about a month ago
and have a live traffic
going on in there.
So let's see what
I can do with this.
I created a query with
typical top talker.
First thing you might
want to do, yes.
And to mix it up a bit, I show
you the top AS numbers traffic
is coming from or going to.
So let's run that query.
And you can see it ran
two and a half seconds
and it processed 1.1 gigs
of data in that case,
because we just needed
a few of the columns.
And the top ASN
there I see there
is 15169, that's Google's own
ASN, so most of the traffic
is internal.
But then if I wanted, I could
dig into all the other traffic
a little bit more.
But digging into AS
numbers not so exciting.
Let's go a little
bit more visual
and let's see what we can
do with Data Studio, which
is our visualization tool have
from Google, which can easily
integrate with BigQuery.
I already connected the
dataset to flow logs,
so let's create a
simple time use graph.
So let me set up a
time series graph.
I need a date range, I use
actually the time stamp
in which the data is coming in.
And let's say I want to see
how much traffic comes in
by continent.
So I select as a
breakdown, the continent.
Destination
continent, and I want
to see not how many
records, but how many bytes
have been sent between
these, from these continent,
or to these continents.
And because half
the traffic comes in
and half the traffic goes out,
most of those are of no use,
I want to filter these, so
I'm going to add this filter.
And it runs the BigQuery
queries in the background,
and within a few
seconds basically, you
can see how much traffic is
coming in from each continent.
So this is how easy you
can generate one graph.
I pre-created some more just
to see what else is possible.
For example, you can see
a simple heat map of where
your traffic is coming from.
Or we can do something a
little bit more exciting.
Here, I did averse around
trip time for my top countries
where the traffic
is coming from.
So I can use that for
planning, which region I
might want to play in.
So my top country
is actually India.
I have a very high
round trip time
from traffic coming from there.
I might want to
look into deploying
the same application in the
Mumbai region if it's possible.
So that's what you can
do with Data Studio.
We also have third
party integrations.
And as I said, it works with
most major CYME software, log
analysis software,
and Sumo Logic
has built pre-created
dashboards on VPC Flow Log.
So you can just add the
dashboard to your applications,
connect Stackdriver
logins through pops up,
and you see all
the data coming in.
And again, you see
similar heat maps
of where traffic comes
from and goes to.
You can look at traffic
by ports, by VMs,
by VPCs where it
goes and comes from.
Also, more complex round trip
time average latency over time
to find [INAUDIBLE].
Or you can obviously
customize this dashboard
with any kind of queries.
So you have many use
cases for VPC Flow Logs.
Can we switch back to slides?
OK, back to the last please.
So from that case
on traffic flows,
looks pretty good, right?
You can do nearly the same
things we've done on premise,
a little bit different.
But also, it's easy to use
that massive amount of data
you can have in the cloud.
But our users want more.
And we did a lot of
research into the area.
So I want to invite Arunima, to
talk about how we did research
in that area.
[APPLAUSE]
ARUNIMA KASHYAP:
Thank you, Jens,
and thank so much,
everyone, for being here.
As Jens said, I
am Arunima, and I
am a user experience researcher
in Google Cloud Platform.
And I truly believe that
I have the best job ever.
Because I get to talk to
you, all of our customers and
bring your feedback into
our PM and eng team members
to build the products that
you need and you want.
So as Jens was mentioning,
over the last few months, me
and my team members with our
fabulous PM and eng team,
were engaged with you
to think about how
to visualize network
topologies and traffic in GCP,
so that we can
actually understand
what to build for you.
Well, why did we
want to do that?
As Jens was mentioning,
if for some of you,
who felt as Jens did, as that
they were a kid from whom
some of their toys that they
had been using in on prem
was taken away,
what we wanted to do
for you is to build
new tools on new toys,
better toys, which will provide
you a good insight into,
and better insights
into GCP networks.
So how did we accomplish this?
I am a researcher,
as I said, and I
wanted to take this
opportunity to tell you
a little bit about
how we do research
in Google and within
Google Cloud Platform.
For us, it's really, really
important to follow the tenet,
focus on the users
and else will follow.
Why do we do this?
Well, this helps us to identify
whether a product or a feature
or a system will
meet users' needs,
so we can build the right
thing, and understand and gain
empathy for our users, so that
we can build the things right.
And I do see some very
familiar faces in the audience,
so thank you so much for coming.
You are the people that
we've been engaged with.
But we conduct variety
of user studies.
We do one-on-one interviews,
we do site visits.
So thanks for welcoming
us at your sites.
And also, we do
customer workshops,
where we bring a
lot of user voice
so that we can understand
your pain points.
Finally, we also do
co-design sessions.
These are really,
really important aspects
of user research and UX
team, because there are three
things that this helps us with.
One, to liberate us
from our own mistakes
by replacing our own personal
assumptions with data
driven requirements.
Second, it prevents us from
building the wrong thing
or improving something
in the wrong way.
And finally, as I
mentioned before,
enables us to discover
the unmet user needs,
and inform prioritization
with our PM and eng team.
So in doing these engagements,
we listened to you.
What we heard, you loved
our load balancing,
our Sankey diagrams
and all the data
that was provided through that.
You also told us and
reached out to us
about some of the VPC flow
logs that Jens was mentioning.
But you also mentioned to us
that even though these products
and features and visualizations
are working out for you,
you needed something more.
There are some gaps and you
wanted us to fill that in.
And that's why I'm
taking this opportunity
to talk to you about these
three things that we've heard.
One is around visual
representation.
Another around
understanding the network.
And finally, diagnosing
network issues.
Why we wanted to talk to you
about this is because if we
have not heard from you,
if you have other use cases
and you want to bring
that information to us,
that's amazing.
Please do feel
free to talk to us.
We'll be here.
So one of the concerns
that you voiced to us,
or the pain points you
talked to us about,
was around the current state
of visual representation
in our console.
What you mentioned
is that what we
have currently, the list of
resources, subnets and cloud
routers and VPN
gateways, et cetera,
they are stored in a very
flat list of resources,
they're very flat.
But that is not
really useful to you,
because in practice,
all of these resources
have a relationship.
They are interrelated, and you
want to see that interrelation.
Second, we also heard that you
want to understand the network
configuration and lay out.
Some of the feedback that we
heard was, it's hard for you
to understand what is connected
to what, how your network
VPC is set up, is redundancies
working well for you
hybrid networking.
Also, the network global state.
So where is the
traffic coming from?
Which geographies
it is originating
and where is it going?
And how is the
traffic being routed?
Finally, at last
but not the least,
we also heard about
diagnosing network issues.
So topics around
troubleshooting,
proactively monitoring
issues, and alerting.
So when something
is not going right,
you wanted to
understand specifically
where the problem is.
Also, you wanted a alerts
around network events,
such as areas that are
operating abnormally.
And then you wanted
some metrics based
on latency, error rates, how
the data is going in and out,
et cetera.
So what did we do
with all of this data?
And specifically
for those customers
who are here, who
we've reached out to
and we've talked to a lot, this
does not go into a black hole,
we promise.
We do look at all of the data.
We brainstorm a lot, so that
we are understanding your pain
points.
And what we saw is
that the emerging theme
was that your needs
were for tools
that will help you visualize,
monitor and troubleshoot
your system so
that we can reduce
your operational overhead.
So we wanted to build this tool.
And for the MVP,
we actually wanted
to hunker down on two
key areas that we had
heard again and again from you.
One was that we
needed to provide you
with visual representation
of network relationship.
And that too, in
context, so that you
can get to the core
of the problem.
And the second is that
you needed metrics
on top of that relationship.
So what did we do with this?
I would hold the
suspense for a little bit
longer, so that Greg can
come and talk about this.
But before that, I want
to have Jens come over
and give a brief overview
of network visualization
and topologies in current
cloud, and in on prem world.
Because as soon as we started
on the path of developing
the network topologies
and visualization
that Greg will talk about,
we had some reality checks.
The reality checks of
what you want and expect
and what we can provide you.
With that, I hand
it over to Jens.
[APPLAUSE]
JENS KUEHLERS:
Thank you, Arunima.
So topology's
important for everyone,
and it always has been.
And unfortunately, always has
been difficult to visualize.
So if you look at on
premise, the first problem
starts with collecting the data.
Like what do you
have in your network?
You might use a
lot of [INAUDIBLE],,
different passwords, et cetera.
So it's not actually
easy to get an inventory.
So I said you need to
use all the protocols.
Cisco's Discovery Protocol,
Link Layer Discovery Protocol,
see what you can reach for, your
SNMP community, go through ARP
tables, IP addresses and
hopefully, somewhere you get
an inventory of your network.
The good thing is,
in Computer Engine,
through the sub APIs
of Compute Engine API,
you have the inventory.
It's all in Compute Engine.
So you have all that data.
The issue is,
context is missing.
You don't know how
to interrelate it.
So let's see how
we've worked on that.
First, on premises.
Let's say you collected
all that data.
You might want to get a nice
network map like the one
pictured on the left.
But in reality, there's lots
of tools that are on topology.
Every network monitoring
suite say they have it,
but they're not
really focused on it.
So mostly you end up with a
graph little bit like that,
something auto generated and
it's not really what you want.
So what do people do?
Well, you do it yourself.
Most people draw network
diagrams, they draw them again,
they try to make them
better, they customize them,
they show them to your
peers, they have them rated,
they make another
view, another layer.
And they're highly
customized and opinionated.
And then in cloud, people
tried the same thing,
but there's two
issues with that.
First of all, it
changes so much.
So you just finished
drawing your diagram,
your network changed again.
Someone deployed something,
it's not up to date anymore.
The second issue is actually
how resources are organized
in the cloud and on premises.
On premises, you have
quite a clear structure.
If data comes from the internet,
it goes through several layers,
several aggregation layers
to top of [INAUDIBLE]
until it hits like you
web application server.
So you have some
grouping right there.
If you look in the cloud,
you have a software
defined network running on
Andromeda through a network
fabric.
Everything is kind of
close to each other.
You talk through
that virtual switch.
You have a flat network.
So how to you actually
do that diagram?
Some people try grouping by
subnet or something else.
But it's not inherent.
So the structure is
a little bit missing.
And that's what's
also the first thing
we've seen when we tried to
look what we can do for you.
And what we made out of
the research of Arunima
and those different realities we
have, I'm going to invite Greg,
and he tell you.
GREG FRANCZYK: OK, so let's
take a moment and recap.
So what we heard from
you was pretty clear.
You want to see
relationships, and then also
need a way to layer
meaningful insights
on top of those relationships.
However, as Jens just mentioned,
visualizing cloud topologies
is not straightforward.
Because the cloud is a mesh.
Everything is talking
to everything else.
It's like a web.
If you remember the
bundle of cables
that Jens had on
the screen earlier,
that's basically what
it looks like when
you visualize 1,000 instances
all talking to themselves.
We're missing
intermediate devices.
Those intermediate
devices add structure
and make your topology
look nice, clean,
and allow you to
navigate it effectively.
So why is that a problem?
Well, without those intermediate
devices, you have that web,
you have so many things
talking to each other,
and you can't
effectively navigate.
However, those intermediate
devices also in a way
structure you into looking
at your topology in a very
specific and a very unique way.
You look at switches,
you look at servers
that are attached the
switches, you look
at core switches and firewalls.
And you can't
necessarily navigate
in the way that's natural to
you and the way you'd like to.
So we realized when
we took a step back,
is that we have an
organizational problem.
And we were using intermediate
devices historically
here in order to fill this
gap of organizing the data
and allowing you to
navigate a complex network.
So we thought about
an alternate mechanism
of structuring the data in a way
that allows you to navigate it.
And a natural way
was hierarchies.
If you take a group
of resources and group
them together, and
you take those groups
and put them into higher
groups and so on and so forth,
you can get to a point where
you have a very clean view
and then you can drill down
and find exactly what you're
looking for.
The ability to select
entities and the ability
to put them into hierarchies
is a key organizational concern
that's necessary in order
to visualize topologies
effectively.
Unfortunately, there's no clean
hierarchy for most resources.
It's unfortunate in
one way, because it
makes our lives a lot harder.
But it's actually very
fortunate for you.
Because that means you
can group things together
in many different ways.
An instance, for instance,
could be in a group.
It could be in a zone.
It could be directly in
a region or in a project.
There's a lot of
different ways to do it.
And rather than
saying we'll create
one hierarchy for
every base resource,
we decided to create
many hierarchies.
Before I give you a demo of the
thing that we're building now,
I want to explain a
few key concepts that
are key to this
organizational structure.
So first, we thought
about base entities.
Based entities are the things
that you're very familiar with.
Things that communicate
on the network.
In an on prem
world, this would be
a server with a network card.
The network card in our
world would be a base entity.
But also things like
your external clients,
things that have IP addresses
outside of your GCP network.
Your on prem, so
your VPN tunnels,
your routers on
prem, the things that
your interconnect
attachments point to,
are all base entities.
We took those base entities,
and then we figured out, OK,
what are hierarchies
that make sense?
So hierarchies, as
I mentioned earlier,
are just groupings of
those base entities
that go higher and higher.
And then a hierarchy family
is a collection of hierarchies
that all ends at the
same base entity.
So if you have a instance,
you can have many hierarchies,
and they all form
a hierarchy family.
These are key navigational
concepts that are important.
So we've organized the data and
we created a structure for it.
So now what can we do?
Well, you saw VPC
flow logs before.
We also have HTTP
load balancer logs
that are in Stackdriver today.
We took this data and we
started to process it.
And what we were
looking for in this data
was relationships and metrics.
The same things that you
identified and let us
know that you really needed.
So let's put this all together.
We created meaningful
hierarchies and a way
to structure the data.
We took relationships
out of the VPC flow
logs and the load balancer logs
that were already receiving.
And then we skimmed
insights off of that
as well, actual metrics.
And then we applied
those metrics
on top of those relationships.
So I'm going to do a demo of
a project that we're building,
of a product that
we're building now.
Before I get into the demo, I
think a little bit of context
is necessary.
So in our demo, we have a
worldwide e-commerce site.
This e-commerce site is made
up of fundamentally four
different applications.
There's a browse component,
a cart component, checkout
and feeds.
It's globally distributed
in three GCP regions.
It's a worldwide
e-commerce shop,
so that's important to them.
And the data has to be
replicated around the world.
So this particular
e-commerce shop
is using a database
solution that's
replicating between GCP regions,
but all reads and writes
are happening locally.
So now that you understand
a little bit about how
the application is
structured, how the company's
infrastructure is
structured, let's
go into a demo of
how you can visualize
and how you can see this
structure in action.
Oh, thanks.
OK, so this is the product
that we are currently building.
We are in an early
preview of this product.
And what you see here is
the Americas, EMEA and APAC.
You see a load
balancer in the middle,
and you see three GCP
regions with dotted lines
moving all over the place.
This is a visual
representation of the project
I just described.
The dotted lines
are traffic that's
flowing between
external sources, a load
balancer and regions.
And this is all generated
dynamically based off
of your project's configuration
and the actual things
that you have going on.
If this customer decided
to create a new GCP region
tomorrow or not create a new
GCP region, but build into one,
that would show up
instantly in this diagram.
So would have alternate
scales with your business.
Now, this view is a
little bit complicated,
because you see a
mixture of things
that are coming through
the load balancer
and also TCP traffic
that's coming directly
from external clients and
going inside the GCP regions
and between them.
Let's take a look
at a view where
we're looking specifically
at just a load balancer.
So here, you've got
three business regions.
Americas, EMEA and APAC.
And you've got a load
balancer sending traffic
to the three regions, just
like on the other view,
except there's a lot less lines
and it's a little bit cleaner.
So now when we look at this,
we can tell specifically
how this traffic is being
distributed by the balancer.
Now let's go through a
load case that's important,
a use case that's important.
As a network admin, I might be
concerned about whether or not
traffic is going to the
closest region to the customer.
The lowest latency
will always be
achieved if the application
that's in that region
is serving those
requests, and it
doesn't have to travel
globally around the world.
So if I hover over APAC, I'll
see some interesting things.
First of all, I'll see
some metrics on the edge.
I know they're
hard to read there,
but it shows that
we're receiving
12 kilobytes of traffic
into the load balancer,
and it's sending 60
kilobytes a second.
On top of that, I can see
that all traffic that's
coming from APAC, is going
directly to the Asia East
1 region, which means that this
is set up properly, looks good.
OK, what's next?
Let's take a look at EMEA.
EMEA, same thing.
I see some metrics on this edge.
How much is going to the
load balancer, and then
I see it's all
traveling to Europe.
But what happens if
I click on Americas?
Ah, in this scenario, I actually
see traffic from the Americas
is going into two
different places.
One, into US Central 1,
and also into Asia East 1.
That's an indicator to the
network admin that hey,
something is wrong here.
This is not optimized.
If my customers in
the US have traffic
being served by
resources in Asia,
it's not optimal for them.
If I open up Asia,
I can take a look
at the different
groups that are there.
I mentioned there was a browse
group, a checkout group,
you see them all here.
I go back, I click
on Americas, and I
see that the traffic that's
flowing through the load
balancer is flowing to just
one of those groups in Asia.
If I open up the US
central 1 region,
I see traffic's
flowing to all of them.
So this is an
indicator to me that
this particular
backend service, which
is made up of three
instance groups,
is sending traffic
to two, instead
of the one that's most closely
correlated with the user.
Now that I have this
view, I can also
use it to pull more information.
So I can open up
the load balancer.
And inside the load
balancer, we see
these are the different
backend services that
match the applications we
were just talking about.
I can click on one
of the backends
and get a time series graph
right on the side, user stacked
driver metrics that show request
count and back and latencies
for that backend service.
Because this is in
Stackdriver, because these
are all Stackdriver
metrics, these
are things you
can set alerts on.
You can use these views to not
only discover your network,
not only see metrics,
but then also use
alerting in order
to operationalize
what you're doing.
Let's go through
another use case.
Since this is a globally
distributed business,
we have traffic moving
between GCP regions.
And as many of you know, traffic
moving between GCP regions
is costly.
It's costly in two ways.
One, if your application
can't read and write locally,
it has to pay a latency
penalty to send traffic
across the world.
But two, it's
actually money costly.
It has an impact on your bill.
So we want to make sure that
all the traffic that's moving in
between GCP regions
is traffic that's
only related to the databases.
No applications are reading
and writing across the world.
So let's see how we can
do that with this view.
First, I can hover
over a region and see
how much traffic is moving
in between the region
and other regions.
If you've ever had to
debug an issue with,
why is my bill so high for
it to reach in traffic,
this would save you a
lot of time, trust me.
If I open up the regions, I
can see instance groups again.
Notice, in the past we
saw four instance groups.
Now we see five.
The fifth one is the
database servers.
They're not seeing any
load balancing traffic,
so they weren't in
the previous view.
It wasn't important
for you there.
Now if I click on, let's say
the database group in Asia,
I can see that
this database group
is talking only
to other database
groups in other
regions, and to all
the applications local to it.
It's an early preview.
We don't have all the metrics
yet, but the metrics we do
have, you see as well.
All right, so this is
the amount of volume
that's coming from
the database group
and going into a
different region.
If there was another
instance group here
also sending traffic, we could
focus on that particular group
and see those metrics as well.
All right, can we go back
to the slides, please?
All right, so some
key takeaways.
We have VPC flow logs.
Those are available in GA today.
They're annotated by default and
easy to integrate with Google
tools, and also
third party tools.
We have Stackdriver
monitoring, which
has been there for everything,
not only for networking.
There, you can get
time series metrics,
you can get logging, all
networking specific as well,
but also programmatic API
access to pull that information.
And finally, the
network topology graph.
So we're currently
in an early preview,
and we're opening
for trusted testers.
We're combining relationship and
metric data into a single view.
And we're organizing
it by hierarchies
to make it easy to consume,
and are very much focused
on the use cases that you need
to solve on a day-to-day basis.
[MUSIC PLAYING]